bonsoir nous sommes le mardi 31 mars
nouvelle édition du Journal de la
rédaction de TVfil 78 l'essentiel de
l'actualité ivelinoise en 26 minutes et
ce soir la Semaine de l'Industrie
jusqu'au 5 avril 73 événements dans le
département pour mieux faire découvrir
le secteur et ses métiers aux jeunes des
échanges direct sont proposé avec les
chefs d'entreprise élu conseillère
départemental dimanche Alexandra Rosetti
repart en campagne pour récupérer son
poste de maire de voisin le Bretonneux
après l'annulation du scrutin trois
nouvelles listes se présentent également
et puis à l'agglomération de cqutin en
iveline a-t-elle une âme c'est la
question que se posera demain le
codeskii le Conseil de Développement
lors de son Assemblée plinière son
président sera notamment en plateau pour
nous apporter des
explications les buralistes sont en
colère cet après-midi ils ont manifesté
devant le ministère de la Santé et
l'Assemblée nationale contre un projet
de loi sur la vente de cigarettes un
texte qui prévoit la mise en place d'un
paquet neutre un paquet sans logo mais
toujours avec des images choquantes sur
l'extérieur de l'emballage pour les
buralistes cette mesure fera baisser les
ventes de cigarettes en France on écoute
Jean-François vigourou le responsable
Eveline de la Fédération des buralistes
c'est au micro de Michel el midero et de
William l en fait on dégrade un peu la
profession on dégrade nos fonds de
commerce et on nous humilie en fait avec
cette cette histoire de package
générique donc on n'est pas contre la
santé publique hein on est prêt on est
prêt à à beaucoup de choses les prix
sont les plus chers d'Europe euh les
taxes sont de plus en plus hautes mais
ce qu'on veut nous c'est une
harmonisation tant dans les dans la
fiscalité que dans tout ce qui est
paquet générique et mention sanitaire on
est prêt à tout hein mais qu'on y aille
tous ensemble et en même temps qu'on
voyait que les pays européens frontalier
baisse surur prix et que nous on
augmente oui la vente de tabac va
baisser en France mais la consommation
ne va pas baisser la consommation va
juste se déplacer si ce texte est
approuvé le paquet neutre rentrerait en
vigueur en application à partir de 2016
et que pensez-vous de la mise en place
de ces paquets neutres est-ce une bonne
idée c'est notre question de jour micro
trottoir il ferait mieux de d'augmenter
les prix des cigarettes et puis voilà
après le paquet neutre je suis pas sû
que ça apporte quoi que ce soit non
hêement je pense pas que ça va changer
grand-chose ben oui je suis plutôt
favorable bien que je fume pas ben comme
ça au moins on verra pas la différence
et puis il y a comment des des symboles
dessus pour essayer d'empêcher de fumer
je pense pas que ça jouera beaucoup pour
ceux qui fument déjà aujourd'hui quand
vous voyez même sur les paquets de
cigarettes vous avez les
photos ça change pas grand-chose les
gens ils fument quand même s'ils ont
envie de fumer chacun fait comme il
souhaite c'est des mesures qui sont
prises inutilement donc pour ma
part c'est le contenu qui est
intéressant enfin qui est dangereux et
pas l'emballage en lui-même donc on
prend des mesures sur un emballage alors
que les mesures sur la cigarette en
elle-même ne sont pas prises visite
d'entreprise atelier pédagogique
conférence exposition c'est le programme
de la Semaine de l'industrie dans le
département actuellement aujourd'hui
c'est un forum ouvert qui s'est tenu
pour les jeunes à la CCI
9685 apprentis sont formés dans les
ivelines cette année Catherine zulato
Patrick Jacques de
Dixmude se tromper si ch fournisseur y a
cette raisonl et aujourd'hui c'est aussi
pour ça que nous en tant que
distributeur on a notre raison d'être le
langage est franc et direct il parle de
son métier avec passion Patrick Mitchell
a créé son entreprise de moyen
d'assemblage pour l'industrie
aéronautique en 97 à Oudan il compte
aujourd'hui 23 salariés et vient
d'ouvrir une filiale au Texas pour
attaquer dit-il le marché américain une
filiale dirigée par un salarié recruté
il y a 4 ans à la sortie de son bac pro
une belle successory à la française
qu'il est venu partager avec ses élèves
souvent peu au fait des réalités du
monde de l'industrie ils le connaissent
pas assez c'est évident j'ai tendance à
dire que c'est peut-être les profs qui
voudra envoyer un stage en entreprise
mais je dis ça très gentiment mais en
tout cas c'est pas les profs qui peuvent
leur expliquer je pense que il faut il
faudrait que même à leur niveau ils
puissent faire des sages en entreprise
plus souvent raconter son expérience et
faire aimer un secteur qui offre des
emplois mais qui a du mal à trouver des
candidats tout l'objectif de ces
rencontres organisé à la CCI via le
réseau coaction t les filières recrutent
plus en moins c'est long effectivement
les les profils les spécificités il y a
beaucoup dans la mécanique qui est très
recherché euh l'aéronautique c'est les
filières dans lesquelle il y a
énormément de de de recherche
aujourd'hui et qui des filières comoche
une vraie découverte en tout cas pour
les 106 élèves reçus ce mardi ils sont
issus de formations très différentes
second professionnel terminal section
technologique ou même classe prépa moi
je connaissais vraiment pas
grand-chosees sur ce secteur là et donc
ça a été extrêmement intéressant de
pouvoir en fait se rendre compte que
c'est pas du tout ce au quoi on pouvait
penser et euh c'était vraiment très
intéressant d'en savoir plus on connaît
pas grand-chose sur l'entreprise et sur
les industries donc ça nous a permis de
déflouter tout ce qu'on savait pas et
c'était vraiment très enrichissant ça
nous permet de de nous ouvrir une
perspective pour la miière pour eux le
l'industrie c'est l'automobile
l'automobile qui qui comment qui qui
licencie mais l'industrie c'est plein
d'autres métiers c'est l'industrie du
lait c'est l'industrie du livre c'est
l'industrie de la cosmétique donc il a
vraiment sur notre territoire une
richesse d'entreprise et de domaines
qu'il faut faire découvrir à nos jeunes
c'est aussi en faisant pétiller des yeux
et en plantant des petites graines que
l'orientation se fait que la réflexion
sur ce qu'on va devenir peut se faire
mission accomplie 20 chefs d'entreprise
ont répondu présent ce jour-là la
Semaine de l'industrie se poursuit
jusqu'au 5 avril ce mercredi un forum de
l'alternance est organisée à
l'université de versaillsint-quentin 150
offres concrètes seront proposées
l'industrie dans les ivelines pourquoi
pas un secteur
anti-rise politique les élections
départementales sont passé mais d'autres
élections attendent maintenant les
habitants de Voisins le bretonneux ce
sont les municipales les électeurs
auront le choix le 12 avril pour le
premier tour entre quatre listes trois
listes à droite et une liste à gauche
Catherine
zulato le dimanche 12 avril les
électeurs vcinois sont appelés aux urn
pour le premier tour de l'élection
municipale partielle ils doivent élir 33
conseillers municipaux après
l'annulation de l'élection le 25 février
dernier les électeurs auront le choix
entre quatre listes tout d'abord la
liste voisin Maville emmenée par Thierry
gasto ancien directeur de cabinet
d'Alexis Biet l'ancien maire de voisin
le Bretonneux Alexis Biet qui figure
assez loin sur cette liste à la 19e
position il ne figure pas non plus parmi
les candidats désignés pour siéger au
conseil communautaire de la casquie
c'est d'ors et déjà un revers pour lui
puisque jusqu'à la décision du Conseil
d'État il siégeait à la communauté
d'agglomération deè liste celle de tous
rassemblé pour voisin porté par Olivier
Afonso 39 ans président de l'association
syndicale champfleuy dans sa liste
figure notamment en 3e position
Jean-Louis tison il avait été tête de
liste en mars 2014 pour les municipales
Olivier affono souhaite défendre des
valeurs d'intérêt général de moralité et
de famille 3ème liste vivre voisin mené
par Alexandra Rosetti la mère sortante
parmi ces colistiers on retrouve ceux
élu en mars dernier gardons le cap son
slogan de campagne le tissu
le vivre ensemble ou encore
l'aménagement reste ses priorités enfin
dernière liste celle de Jean ha élu de
gauche avec pour voisin avec vous Jean h
est conseiller municipal à voisin de
bretonnais depuis 95 dans sa lettre
d'intention l'élu d'opposition veut
défendre les valeurs de gauche et
d'humanisme que sont pour lui la justice
sociale la solidarité ou le cadre de vie
les élections municipales de voisin le
bretonnais avait été annulé par le
Conseil d'État le 25 février après le
recours déposé par l'ancien maire Alex
Biet en cause l'écart de 15 voix
seulement entre lui et Alexandra Rosetti
et la diffusion de tract le samedi du
second tour ce qui était interdit
premier tour donc de cette municipale
partiel le dimanche 12
avril les invités de cette édition à
présent ils sont de Yv lchamp et Viviane
Boussier bonsoir à tous les deux
président et membre du codeskii le
conseil en développement de
Saint-Quentin en Yveline qui tient son
assemblée plainère demain 1er avril 19h
salle du conseil communautaire à la
communauté d'agglomération c'est att
trrappe le thème et si Saint-Quentin
avait une âme forcément pourquoi cette
question parce qu'on dit souvent que les
les villes nouvelles al maintenant
anciennement villes nouvelles sont sont
froides oui enfin Saint-Quentin c'est
quand même une ville qui est assez
réussie elle est reconnue comme telle
hein elle a un gros dynamisme point de
vue économique il a une belle
université mais effectivement alors
c'est une belle qualité de vie aussi
mais effectivement on a souvent des des
des échos comme quoi ben oui mais
SaintQuentin ça manque un petit peu
d'animation c'est pas animé le soir
voilà donc on s'est dit ben on va
essayer de voir ce qu'en pense les gens
qui vont participer à cette assemblée
plinièire alors ce sont les membres du
codeesqui mais c'est une assemblée
plinièire ouverte donc à laquelle les
habit tous les 5inois peuvent participer
apporter leurs réflexion des réflexions
qui vont ensuite nourrir l'action des
politiques c'est le principe du du
codesqui he tout à fait exactement par
rapport à cette question justement quel
regard vous avez si Saint-Quentin avait
une âme pour vous est-ce que
Saint-Quentin a une âme aujourd'hui euh
SaintQuentin n'a pas tout à fait je
crois une âme je crois que ça manque
ouaà je pense que SaintQuentin c'est
vrai que c'est une ville qui est
dynamique c'est une ville où il fait bon
vivre c'est une ville où on est bien
seulement il n'y a pas de cœur de ville
et la ville n'est quand même pas
tellement animé en particulier pour les
jeunes d'où si cquentin avait une âme
comment comment faire alors c'est
difficile il y aura toujours une
problématique c'est qu'il n'y a pas de
de centreeville à proprement parler
puisqu'il y a plusieurs villes il y en a
SEP et ça va même s'aggraver j'ai envie
de dire puisqu'il y a encore plus de
communes à partir de 2016 plaisir les
clés qui vont rejoindre SaintQuentin en
yeline ce sera encore plus grand quelle
solution peut apporter à tout ça il y a
des pistes il y a des choses vous avez
déjà des réflexions on a il a il y a
effectivement des pistes de réflexion en
matière de centre-ville effectivement
bon il y a des des grands projets pour
50 en Eveline qui qui font l'objet de de
de réflexion après il faudra voir
comment elles pourront être financé mais
ça c'est une autre histoire euh et
effectivement on peut dans dans le dans
ce cadre là envisager qu'il y ait un
centre-ville qui soit qui qui apporte
effectivement cette C cette à 5 qutin
ceci étant il y a pas que ça quand même
pour créer le l'âme dans une ville et ce
qu'on voudrait aussi dans cette dans
cette assemblée plinière demain c'est
d'avoir la vie des gens sur qu'est-ce
que c'est avoir une âme pour une ville
on va certainement découvrir des tas de
choses auxquelles on n pas pensé voilà
parce que saqutin onel a une certaine
richesse aussi il y a ce label de ville
d'art et d'histoire aussi qui a été
décerné il y a quelques années ça les
gens l'ignorent peut-être mais il y a
matière déjà il y a y a un vivier il y a
quelques chose qui existe on a une vie
associative qui est très riche il y a
toute une histoire culturelle de cette
de cette vie associative depuis les
années 70 donc depuis le début de la
création de la ville nouvelle donc il y
a quand même une histoire il y a quand
même beaucoup de choses peut-être qu'il
faut peu de choses pour qu'il a
de façon beaucoup plus je dirais vivante
pour les pour les habitants quoi
beaucoup plus ressenti les habit et pour
les jeunes voilà et alors justement
puisque tu parlais de la la vie
associative ce sera mais je pense qu'on
va revenir un des des trois ateliers de
la soirée de demain que justement quel
est le rôle quelle est la place et le
rôle de la vie associative pour
justement animer donner une ville donner
une vie une âme pardon à à 5 ou il y a
pas que les pouvoirs publics il faut que
les habitants se saisissent aussi de la
problématique pour donner une
une me et peut-être aussi parce que tu
as peut-être un petit peu oublié enfin
pas oublié mais là non seulement une âme
mais aussi une identité Saint-Quentin et
vous disiez avec raison l'agglomération
va s'agrandir justement comment créer
une identité pour bah pour tous ces gens
un point commun entre les différents
habitants des différentes communes qui
vont composer 5quentin en Yveline à
partir de de 2016 avec ces différentes
communes comme plaisir les CLIS morpa
qui vont rejoindre 50 ans nieline ou
encore coanière comment ça va
s'organiser sur ces séances sur
l'assemblée plinière de demain il y a
des invités chaque année lorsque vous
organisez ces événements alors demain
nous avons deux invités nous avons
premièrement un invité universitaire qui
est spécialiste dans l'urbanisme et et
la sociologie urbaine qui va nous dire
un peu que bon un centre urbain ça un
cœur urbain ça peut se construire mais
ça ne se décrète pas il faut ensuite que
les habitants et tout le tissu urbain
tout tout le tissu des habitants et de
des associations et de l'ensemble et des
commerçants et cetera s'approprie et en
face un véritable cœur urbain donc ça
c'est une première chose et puis un
deuxième invité ça sera un témoignage
sur les machines de Nantes les Machines
de l'île au sens de l'île de Nantes à
Nant qui est une une une réalisation
assez assez remarquable qui
combine dans le cadre d'un de la
reconstruction d'un cœur urbain ou du
moins d'un quartier urbain sur les
anciens chantiers navals donc une une
réalisation qui a à côté à la fois
décalé culturel d'animation euh voilà
qui est un peu exceptionnel un peu un
peu spécifique et et don que les Nanta
se sont tout à fait appropriés et qui a
maintenant un rayonnement mondial ça ce
sera pour les témoignage avec les deux
intervenants qui sont présents il y a
ces ateliers aussi et là le public va
devoir participer s'impliquer exactement
voilà donc il y a je commence donc il y
a trois ateliers participatif en effet
un atelier qui est plus l'aspect
urbanisme en quelque sorte
hein qui qui fait la ville comment
justement ce que vous disiez peut se
construire à cœur deeville il y a un
deuxième atelier qui est
plutôt porte qui porte plutôt donc sur
le monde associatif quelle est la place
comme on le disait il a le rôle le rôle
et la place du monde associatif et il y
a enfin le troisème atelier qui est
vraiment réservé pour les jeunes pour un
jeune c'est quoi une ville qui bouge
qu'est-ce qu'ils peuvent apporter
comment est-ce qu'ils voient cette ville
surtout que n'est porté aussi par son
université voilà une ville universitaire
une ville avec des des grandes écoles
écoles supérieur donc comment est-ce que
tout ceci peut animer et faire justement
ce cœur de ville tout ça c'est le
travail qui va se dérouler demain à
partir de 19h attrape au sein de la la
communauté d'agglomération de 5 an
nveline au sein du conseil communautaire
pour ceux qui veulent y participer ça
c'est pour le travail de demain et
ensuite comment vous allez compiler
comment tout cela va remonter au pouvoir
public alors on organise les les
ateliers notamment de manière àement
avoir beaucoup de de déchange et
beaucoup de de matières qui vont nous
apporter les les participants donc on
compte faire d'une part un
document qui résume ces différents ces
différents éléments et puis nous
poursuivre nos réflexions à partir de là
dans le cadre de nos réflexions sur
l'urbanisme de de Saint-Quentin
puisqu'il y a le plan local d'urbanisme
intercommunal par exemple ou d'autres
d'autres réflexions concernant
l'urbanisme et aussi dans le cadre du
désveloppement de la vie associative du
rôle de la culture et puis
éventuellement d'autres initiatives qui
peuvent être prises euh les relations
avec l'université l'enracinement de
l'université dans la ville comment les
jeunes travailleurs aussi peuvent
trouver leur place dans dans cette ville
pour en faire non seulement une ville
une ville dynamique mais une ville jeune
on a on a plein de jeunes dans cette
ville mais on les voit pas suffisamment
en tout cas bien levier aussi c'est le
levier économique parce que vous l'avez
abordé brièvement tout à l'heure mais
forcément ça ça peut nécessiter des
investissements aussi et là vous pensez
que les pouvoirs publics sont réceptifs
en ces périodes de de 10 économique
c'est un peu compliqué c'est souhaitable
mant c'est une nécessité de justement de
créer une âme pour pour l'avenir c'est
important aujourd'hui de se pencher sur
cette question là c'est pas forcément il
y a peut-être des beaucoup d'initiatives
à prendre qui nécessitent pas forcément
des gros budgets euh par exemple de
reprendre un local industriel et et d'en
faire un lieu de culture un peu
décalé que les gens vont pouvoir
s'approprier pour en faire des arts des
arts de la rue des arts vraiment de de
ouverts et nouveaux ça nécessite pas
forcément beaucoup d'investissement
d'ailleurs l'exemple de des machines de
lent enfin les machines de lent en sont
un exemple dans la mesure où le bâtiment
lui-même les anciens chantiers naval a
été rénové à relativement peu de frais
après c'est les attractions qui ell on
on nécessiter un budget mais on n'est
pas obligé de faire la même chose à
Saint-Quentin bien entendu donc il y a
peut-être des idées à voir sans
forcément euh de gros investissement et
donc il deviennent réaliste ouis pour
les renseignements pratiques demain 19h
il faut être à l'heure ça commence des
19h comment ça se passe sur la soirée
oui on va essayer de commencer des 19h
effectivement et puis alors il est
préférable de s'inscrire auprès du codes
de signaler de manière à ce qu'on puisse
organiser ensuite la salle en fonction
du nombre de personnes qui vont qui vont
venir donc pour ça il y a une il y a
donc une une information qui est sur le
site du codesqui ou sur le site de la
Communauté d'Agglomération euh avec un
lien qui permet de de s'inscrire très
facilement il suffit de cliquer puis de
oui mais on peut venir aussi sans
s'inscrire on peut venir sans s'inscrire
pour ceux qui décideront la dernière
minut on a personnes qui viennent sans
s'inscrire plus on peut préparer la
salle oui les deux sont possibles en
tout cas merci d'être venu sur ce
plateau le CODES ski le conseil en
développement de 50 ans en Yveline qui
tient son assemblée plinière ouverte je
le reprécise demain 1er avril à 19h
salle du conseil communautaire
communauté d'agglomération c'est rappe
merci encore merci le journal qui se
poursuit à présent avec ce matin une
opération de sensibilisation à la gare
de Saint-Quentin en Yveline les employés
de skibus sont rappelés aux passagers
l'importance de valider leur titre de
transport notamment sur la ligne 475
pour connaître la fréquentation et
améliorer ensuite le trafic malgré
l'arrivée du tramou le bus effectue la
liaison entre Paris et hencour et il ne
désemplie pas avec environ 700 usagers
journalier le souci de de cette ligne
475 c'est que l'arrivée du
tramou effectivement nous a fait
craindre que cette ligne soit supprimée
ou du moins soit raccourcie on s'est
aperçu au contraire que la ligne avec
les développements qui ont eu lieu en en
janvier de l'année dernière a fait que
cette ligne a vraiment progressé et que
la fréquentation a plutôt augmenté sur
les quatre courses du matin entre 7h et
8h on a voulu faire un geste commercial
pour nos clients et on leur a offert un
petit autocar miniature en leur
expliquant la démarche et surtout en
leur expliquant qu'il faut bien valider
les types de transport dans ce dans cet
autocar puisque c'est la validation qui
nous prouve et qui prouve surtout
autif qui prouve au sttif qu'il y a du
monde dans le bus un tout autre sujet à
présent créer un discours en s'inspirant
de celui prononcé par Martin Luther King
lors de la célèbre manifestation du 28
août 1963 consacrée à la défense des
droits CIVIS aux États-Unis c'était le
thème d'un concours organisé pour les
étudiants de première année de licence
de l'Université de Versailles 50 ans en
yvelin les prix viennent tout juste
d'être décerné le reportage est signé
Mathilde
capberne les premières années de
l'Institut des Études culturel et
international ont fait un rêve un rêve
de liberté d'égalité et de fraternité
ces étudiants ont participé à un
concours autour de Martin Luther King
ils ont dû présenter un discours à la
fois écrit et filmé une grande première
pour ses étudiants dont la promotion
porte le nom du célèbre militant pour
les droits civiques des Noirs aux
États-Unis c'était leur donner
l'occasion juste de s'exprimer he dans
un université où souvent en France on
accuse l'université d'être de faire de
de de de de former des étudiants un peu
trop passifs donc justement il fallait
leur donner à eux la parole et nous
c'était à nous de les écouter et ce qui
nous a frappé c'est de voir que les
étudiants étit assez timide en fait face
à cet exercice du discours nont pas osé
comme si par rapport à un travail plus
classique universitaire le discours les
mettait un peu plus à nu les
participants ont été jugés sur la
qualité de l'écriture l'éloquence et
l'enregistre
prierér en
plus perett deutter àre manière contre
la discrimination raciale non seulement
France mais partout dans le monde pas
juste
participours assist à une conférence
débat autour de Martin Luther King
l'objectif mieux comprendre le
personnage je trouve c'est très
audacieux très original j'ai essayé de
leur donner quelques pistes sur le type
de Martin Luther King qui pourrait qu'il
pourrait vouloir célébrer c'est
compliqué d'importer des gens qui sont
des cultes comme ça qui sont des icônes
de la de la vie d'un autre pays et en
même temps je voulais qu'ils comprennent
ce qu'il y avait d'international et
d'intemporel chez Martin Luther King et
je pense que voilà sans doute ils
réfléchiront différemment ensuite en
tout cas j'espère l'Institut compte
réitéré ce concours l'abbé Pierre
Kennedy Simon veale l'exercice dépendra
du nom de la prochaine
promotion nous partons pour Versailles à
présent qui a célébré le retour du
printemps et les bourgeons avec sa 7e
édition d'esprit jardin les 28 et 29
mars qui mettaient en lumière la
thématique de la biodiversité une
manifestation et qui doit permettre de
renouer avec la vocation de ville Jardin
de la cité royale c'est ce qu'annoncé
les organisateurs Mélanie Pok est allé
vérifier sur place
et si vous regardiez de temps en temps
où vous mettez les pieds parce que la
ville ce ne sont pas que des routes et
des bâtiments aux alentours d'un banc ou
d'un escalier on peut trouver des
plantes sauvages l'Observatoire sauvage
de Mar rue essaie de toutes les recenser
sauvage de marue c'est c'est de de de
connaître en fait l'impact de la matrice
urbaine en fait c'est-à-dire de du bâti
sur les espèces sauvages qui poussent
spontanément en naturel il y a un
brassage en fait qui se fait
naturellement et donc il y a des
échanges il y a des il y a des flux de
gèes de pollen et cetera et donc ce
brassage en ville il est il est entravé
en fait mais on ne connaît pas l'impact
du milieu urbain sur la sur les plantes
sur leur survie leur reproduction alors
je vous propose de regarder cette plante
là cette plante ici donc de couleur
blanche et puis après elle a ces tiges
qui partent de cette rosette
alors est-ce que vous observez donc la
la différence en fait de forme des
feuilles entre cell qui sont à la base
et celles qui sont le long de la tige
initié par un chercheur du Muséum
d'Histoire Naturelle sauvage de marue a
créé un manuel qui rassemble
actuellement 250 plantes présentes dans
les rues des villes et des villages on
va trouver des plantes qui ont que
normalement on trouve plutôt sur les
bords de chemin comme peut-être les pic
en lit
les les endroits qui ont été un peu
remués vous
voyez des des milieux perturbés où il y
a de la présence humaine des Ortis par
exemple on va retrouver aussi le Paturin
le Paturin qui est donc une une herbe
une graminée qui va être très fréquente
et surtout qui va retenir la terre on va
la trouver en pied d'arbr pour les
dénombrer l'Observatoire fait appel à
des bénévoles aujourd'hui Marie est
initié pour peut-être devenir l'un
d'entre eux après cette visite c'est
vrai que ça me donne envie de plus
regarder les les murailles les pieds de
mur ou même dans les graviers il y a
tout un tas de d'herbes de de plantes de
petites fleurs à chaque plante trouvée
le bénévole remplit une fiche de terrain
informant du lieu et de la description
de la plante à destination de
l'Observatoire pour peut-être découvrir
de nouvelles espèces fr oui
et on va terminer ce journal en musique
avec gwenel Rousel c'est une artiste
yvelinoise qui va participer demain
mercredi à l'émission d'Éric Bastien sur
France Bleue Île-de-France elle en sera
l'artiste découverte vous pourrez la
retrouver pour une interview en direct à
19h45 voici un extrait de son titre
phare
Merlin mon cœur avait ravi par vos
charmes et par vos souris
c'est vrai que je vous ai trah et vous
sor mon
serv à vous gardez bien à l'AB et que
s'accomplisse la
prophétie le journal revient demain un
mercredi aux mêmes horaires et puis je
vous retrouve également dans quelques
instants pour un nouveau 7 h politique
largement consacré au résultats des
élections départementales nous parlerons
aussi des élections municipales à voisin
le Bretonneux excellente
soirée